yeah you ever hooked up with girls bad
breath you know what I have found over
and I don't find it as much anymore but
there was a period probably in the
2012-2013 time I noticed a lot of women
had this meaty these kind of ham smell
around their mouth a little bit a meat
smell you mean like deli meat yeah kind
of just like a subway smell I hate
something rose all the ways that
brooches in them - somebody's at a
subway right now listening to this dude
it's Rob leave yeah have you noticed
this cuz I said to my buddy I was with a
vegan girl and he said she smell a
little bit I go yeah her breath he goes
yep and it's sometimes vegans no offense
to any vegan I know some vegan girls I
think it was the maybe she was eating a
lot of Muslims
it smelled like mush that girl might
just melt like [ __ ] though it's
happening somebody got chalk it up -
yeah yeah
some people have fungus in them yeah
they just don't smell I know I don't
like I had a friend [ __ ] it a manager
you know is his breath was so bad it
would ricochet off the window when we
were driving I told Brian you gotta say
so I told Brian like you have forgot to
say some new brands like I'm not saying
[ __ ] we shouldn't I love them and I love
them too I think yeah you said he had
malaria and might be the liver yeah oh
yeah oh yeah or he's eating [ __ ] so
liver liver disease can cause really bad
breath yeah and liver problems can cause
really bad breath and other times it's
there a couple things one it can be a
cavity but the other thing it can be is
sulfates versus sulfides like the sulfur
in your mouth takes on a different form
so it can be little I'm talking about
you got to be pH balanced to get the
pool gotta [ __ ] ya ptosis I'm talking
about the worst Brett it would shut the
car down yeah like you get out and feel
sick yeah yeah yeah kisum I got a Google
Voice number and I will send blind text
messages people had a really bad breath
great I do active yeah people tell me
this guy's bad breath that's kind of
nice well just it's such a horrible
thing to let someone go through life
with you know it's like it's like
somebody doesn't have a leg but you
don't tell them and they're constantly
just trying to fall and there's no
wonder why that man
like that who I should have talked to
and I couldn't bad rabbit and I remember
one girl goes I can't keep a man don't
know I was like I don't your [ __ ]
brethren terrible breath she smelled
like her breath always smelled like new
hot enough I'll put up some bad breath I
did I was out a girl who had a pierced
tongue mm-hmm and she didn't really take
care of it wash that and her breath was
like a it was like a muffler like a
corroded muffler taste that rust so like
there's like rusty she tastes like a 76
Dodge that are iron in her blood you
were tasting blood from her [ __ ]
tongue that's the iron no no no I'm
telling ya I think it was the ball fee
cuz this is early 2000 1999 she had that
ball it wasn't stainless steel it was
just a rough oh yeah we're on piercing
tongues was like a big fish yeah
what the [ __ ] you never had like a stud
in your tongue or lip
I never had anything like that man I'm
trying to cover I ever thought of
getting anything exotic dude yeah he got
his belly button pierced at Spring Break
one time and then a couple kids beat him
that's all I remember
that makes sense yeah what about a nose
ring nope you know how nose ring no Joel
no you look sick with a nose I would
look I would get slaughtered
no you wouldn't bro you're a solid I'd
say eight or nine your nose ring you
attend I'm gonna weigh your southern ten
nine bro southern nine yeah la nines
different rules yeah you have to be gay
first of all as a man to be in LA nine
yeah so that's like a nine solves like a
nine and you do 210 is you gay you know
there's nothing wrong with that but
you're still dude if you're a third time
I'm an eighth with a nose ring you're
ten sharp with the nose ring I'm Angus
why don't you get a [ __ ] listen to me
I'm being dead serious now you could
actually because you're so big you could
actually kind of get away with a tiny
tiniest tiny diamond stud in your nose
oh I need to do that cuz you're if it's
not for me I'm talking feel just gets a
little ring like like
like Lenny Kravitz not getting a [ __ ]
nose dude you would love yes I keep a
spare key on it no no no comic as their
nose ring no you can't do it
imagine if Richard Power had a know
times are different a nose ring right
there that terrible [ __ ] career
advice from Brandon is right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]